bet against me tell me it's not going to
happen tell me it's going to fail I love
it I love every minute of
it I couldn't do it the all I couldn't
do it look at me now they wrote me off I
ain't right back though that's the
problem I Ain right back let's go I'm
going to show you how great I am in that
dark room is who you are but in that
dark room is where you have to create
another human being that walks out of
that dark room you need something that
you know you need something to get out
of bed for and fight for if there's
potential inside of you which you know
it's there but you're too scared to tell
anyone else about it and you go on and
on get older and older and older and
older and the windows of opportunity
start to close and you knew it could
have been given birth to but you never
did it I promise you it will haunt
you it'll be more it's a living
nightmare dude